you write that the phenomenon of
emergence collective behavior exhibited
by a large collection of simple elements
in interaction
is one of the things that got you into
neural nets in the first place i love
cellular i love simple
interacting elements and the things that
emerge from them do you think
we understand how complex systems can
emerge from such simple components that
interact simply no we don't
it's a big mystery also it's a mystery
for physicists it's a mystery for
biologists um
you know how is it that uh
the uh
universe around us seems to be
increasing in complexity and not
decreasing
i mean that that is a kind of
curious property of
physics that despite the second law of
thermodynamics
we seem to be you know evolution and and
learning and uh et cetera seems to be
kind of at least locally
uh to increase
complexity not decrease it so perhaps
the ultimate purpose of the universe is
to just get more complex
have these
i mean
uh small pockets of beautiful complexity
does that to cellular autonomous these
kinds of emergence and complex systems
give you some intuition or guide
your understanding of machine learning
systems neural networks and so on or are
these for you right now desperate
concepts well you got it got me into it
you know i uh i discovered the existence
of uh the perceptron when i was a
college student um
you know by really good book and it was
a debate between chomsky and piaget and
seymour pepper from mit was kind of
singing the praise of the perception in
that book and i i the first time i heard
about the running machine right so i
started digging the literature and i
found those paper those books which were
basically trans transcription of you
know
workshops or conferences
from the 50s and 60s about
self-organizing systems
so there were there was a series of
conferences on self-organizing systems
and the these books on this um some of
them are
you can actually get them at the
internet archive you know the
digital version
and there are like uh fascinating
articles in there by this guy whose name
has been largely forgotten heinz von
firster
he's a german physicist who immigrated
to the u.s
and uh worked on self-organizing systems
uh in the in the 50s
and in the 60s he created at university
in urbana-champaign he created the
biological computer laboratory bcl
which was you know all about neural nets
unfortunately that was kind of towards
the end of the popularity of neural nets
so that that lab never kind of strived
very much but but he wrote a bunch of
papers about self-organization and the
mystery of self-organization an example
he has is you take imagine you are in
space there's no gravity you have a big
box with
magnets in it okay um you know what kind
of rectangular magnets with north pole
on one end south pole on the other end
you shake the box gently and the magnets
will kind of stick to themselves and
probably form a complex structure
you know spontaneously um you know that
could be an example of self-organization
but you know you have lots of examples
neural nets are an example of
self-organization to
you know in many respects
and it's a it's a bit of a mystery um
you know how
like what what is possible with this um
you know pattern formation in physical
systems
in chaotic system and things like that
you know you know the emergence of life
you know things like that so you know
how does
does that happen
it's a it's a big puzzle for for
physicists as well it feels like
understanding this
the the mathematics
of emergence in some constrained
situations might help us create
intelligence
like uh help us
add a little spice to the systems
because um you seem to be able to
in complex systems with emergence to be
able to get a lot from little
and so that seems like a shortcut
to get big leaps in performance
but um but there's there's a missing
conservative concept that we are we
don't have yeah uh and it's uh it's
something also i've been fascinated by
since uh my undergrad days and it's how
you measure complexity
right so we don't actually have good
ways of measuring or at least we don't
have good ways of interpreting
the measures that we we have at our
disposal like how do you measure the
complexity of something right
so there's all those things you know
like you know common goal of chatting
solomon of complexity of you know the
length of the shortest program that
would generate a bit string can be
thought of as the complexity of that bit
string right
i've been fascinated by that concept the
problem with that is that
that complexity is defined up to a
constant which can be very large
right there's there are similar concepts
that are derived from you know
you know bayesian probability theory
where you know the complexity of
something is
the negative log of its probability
essentially right and you have a
complete equivalence between the two
things
and then you would think you know the
probability is something that's well
defined mathematically which means
complexity is well defined but it's not
true you need to have a model of
of of the distribution
and you may need to have a prior if
you're doing bayesian inference and the
prior plays the same role as the choice
of the computer with which you measure
your graph complexity and so every
measure of complexity we have has some
arbitrary necessity
you know an additive constant which
is can be arbitrarily large and so you
know how can we come up with a good
theory of how things become more complex
if we don't have a good measure of
complexity yeah which we need for this
one way that people study this in the
space of biology the people that study
the origin of life or try to recreate
the life in in the laboratory
and the more interesting one is the
alien one is when we go to other planets
how do we recognize this life
because you know complexity we associate
complexity maybe some level of mobility
with life
you know we have to be able to like have
concrete
algorithms for like
um measuring the level of complexity we
see in order to know the difference
between life and non-life and the
problem is that complexity is in the eye
of the beholder so let me give you an
example if i um if i give you uh
an image of the endless digits right and
i flip through in this digits there is
some obviously some structure to it
because
local structure you know neighboring
pixels are correlated uh
across the entire data set
now imagine that uh
i apply a random permutation to all the
pixels
a fixed random permutation now i show
you those images they will look
you know really disorganized to you more
complex
in fact they're not more complex in
absolute terms they're exactly the same
as originally right and if you knew what
the permutation was you know you could
undo the permutation
now
imagine i give you special glasses that
undo that permutation
now all of a sudden what looked
complicated becomes simple right so if
you have two if you have you know humans
on one end and then another race of
aliens that sees the universe with
permutation glasses yeah with the
permutation glasses
what we perceive as simple to them is
hardly complicated it's probably heat
yeah heat yeah okay and what they
perceive as simple to us is is random uh
fluctuation it's heat yeah
so truly in the eye of the beholder it
depends what kind of glasses you're
wearing right depends what kind of
algorithm you're running in your
perception system so i don't think we'll
have a theory of intelligence
self-organization evolution things like
this until we have a good handle on a
notion of complexity which we know is in
the higher the eye of the beholder
yeah it's sad to think that we might not
be able to detect or interact with alien
species because we're wearing different
glasses
um because their notion locality might
be different from ours yeah this
actually connects with fascinating
questions in physics at the moment like
modern physics
uh quantum physics like you know
questions about like you know can we
recover the information that's lost in a
black hole and things like this right
and uh and that relies on notions of
complexity um
which you know i find i find this
fascinating
you